bonjour katia vous avez suivi ce procès
depuis le début c'est un procès qualifié
d'historique
qu'est ce que cela signifie concrètement
ou alors il est historique à plus d'un
titre 1 tout d'abord par son objet
l'assassinât des journalistes de charlie
hebdo des personnes juives de l'hyper
cacher donc la tacc de la liberté
d'expression l'antisémitisme mais il est
aussi historique par son dispositif
parce qu'elle est d'une ampleur inégalée
il y a eu cinquante quatre jours
d'audience sur trois mois une centaine
d'avocats 200 parties civiles environ
150 témoin le procès était filmé ça
aussi c'est très rare et au vu de
l'affluence
il a été diffusé dans quatre salles nous
avons également assisté à un défilé de
ténor du barreau comme richard malka
patrick klugman et où pour ne citer
qu'eux évidemment et au niveau de la
défense c'était pour les parties civiles
il ya eu
l'avocate de carlos isabelle coûtant
peyre marie dosé avec des plaidoiries
magnifique humaniste qui feront date un
plaidoirie aussi historique
et puis il a eu la parole de ses
victimes les parties civiles les paroles
des survivants de charlie hebdo
extrêmement forte des appels à lutter
contre le totalitarisme x l'islamiste et
puis les proches des disparus dont
beaucoup de larmes beaucoup d'émotion je
dois ajouter qu il a eu également au
cours de ce procès deux attentats une
interruption pour cause de kobe deux des
accusés
précisément et les accusés katia et bien
justement c'était un peu la surprise au
cours de ce procès parce que on a on ne
s'attendait pas forcément à ces profils
alors tout d'abord il faut parler
d'agathe boumediane inquiétait la
compagne de midi coulibaly elle est en
fuite
les deux frères belhoucine qui sont au
coeur du projet d'attentât a priori mais
eux sont présumés morts et pour les
autres c'est soit des connaissances ou
amis d'amis dit coulibaly parfois
connaissance très lointaine ils sont
suspectés d'avoir acheté fourni
transporter des armes légales ou
illégales et de l'autre côté les des
trafiquants du nord et de belgique alors
eux qui connaissent encore moins à mehdi
coulibaly alors était-il tous autant
qu'ils sont au courant des intentions
terroristes d'hamidi coulibaly départ
kwasi et bien c'est tout l'enjeu du
procès justement et on parle aussi d'un
procès frustrant pourquoi alors oui il
est frustrant à plus d'un titre
tout d'abord sonné
il est comment discerner les auteurs que
l'on juge parce que soit ils sont beaux
ils sont en fuite
ayad boumédiène pour ne parler que
d'elle et bien elle a fui mais du canda
lol au kurdistan donc on aurait très
bien pu la récupérer je pense que
beaucoup de parties civiles aurait aimé
qu'elle réponde de ses actes mais ce ne
sera donc pas possible
et puis il ya la question de la
responsabilité les avocats de la défense
ont beaucoup dénoncé une accusation très
fragile un manque de preuves
c'est vrai que pour estimer si ces
accusés sont coupables ou non d'avoir dû
des intentions terroristes d'être
complice ou alors vraiment de d'être
d'être coupable d'association de
malfaiteurs à caractère terroriste
il faut des preuves et il y à des
éléments de téléphonie évidemment mais
finalement très peu de preuves donc les
avocats de la défense se sont beaucoup
emporté contre cela et je vous propose
d'écouter des vues diamétralement
opposées d'isabelle coûtant peyre qui
est l'avocate du principal accusé et m
elie korchia vos quatre parties civiles
on espère du côté des parties civiles je
tiens à vous dire que la phrase qui a
été prononcée par madame l'avocate
générale sera suivie
lorsqu'elle a demandé aux magistrats aux
cinq magistrats qui auront à juger ce
dossier que leur main ne tremble pas au
moment où ils devront délibérer et que
cette condamnation
au regard de l'importance tant nationale
qu'internationale quand ils ces
attentats et bien que cette condamnation
à l'encontre du principal accusé soit
effectivement cette peine qui a été
requis ce matin les responsables ceux
qui devraient être jugées sont pas dans
les boxes et c'est pas des arguments de
défense
je pense qu'on a c'est une affaire
d'état c'est une affaire d'état
l'état est moderne présenter à l'opinion
publique dé des hommes de paille les
hommes de paille et qui sont pour rien
dans ce qui s'est passé c'est
parfaitement clair ne sont pour rien
dans ce qui s'est passé et puis il y a
une grande frustration aussi comme je
vous disais il ya peu de preuves mais il
ya une certitude qui a vendu les armes
au départ de la chaîne
eh bien il s'agit de claude hermant un
identitaire lillois qui était aussi
indique il a été arrêté juste après les
attentats mais aussi surprenant que cela
puisse paraître il ne figure pas dans ce
procès il a été jugé à lille pour vente
d'armes
elle a pris finalement très peu d'années
de prison et en fait on va juger des
hommes sur le fait qu'ils aient vendu
des armes ou transporter des armes
il aurait était donc crucial d'avoir
claude hermant dans ce procès afin de
retracer toute cette chaîne pour le
moment cette chaîne ne repose que sur
des hypothèses du parquet c'est assez
faible et c'est aussi tout à fait
étonnant d'entendre une des personnes
rescapées de l'attentât de charlie hebdo
a grièvement blessé demandé dans la
salle d'audience entre les audiences
justement de demander à votre avis sont
ils coupables ou non même des personnes
de charlie hebdo peuvent s'interroger
sur l'implication des uns et des autres
donc il ya eu beaucoup de douleur dans
ce procès d'appel à se battre pour la
liberté d'expression mais c'est aussi un
procès plein de zones d'ombré qui laisse
plus de questions que de réponses
merci beaucoup catia pour toutes ces
précisions vous nous rendrez compte
évidemment à partir de 16h et bien avant
à partir de 16h en tout cas le verdict
sera donc rendu aujourd'hui à la cour
d'assises de paris pour ce premier
procès peut être le premier d'une longue
liste de procès à venir sur le
terrorisme